après des jours d'effort désespéré des
secouristes réussissent à extirper cette
femme coincée sous les débris depuis 222
heures plus de 9 jours
madame et maman Glou est encore bien
vivante elle répond clairement à ses
sauvages pour leur plus grand bonheur
c'est sauvetages inespérés se sont
répétées plusieurs fois en ce neuvième
jour de recherche cette femme
âgée de 74 ans est resté piégé 226
heures sous les gravats les secouristes
veulent à tout prix sauver les personnes
qu'ils entendent crier sous les débris
quand ils réussissait sa les sortir
vivant certains pleurent de joie
dans les hôpitaux débordés des
survivants commencent à témoigner cette
femme et son fils sont restés coincés
pendant cinq jours sous les ruines de
l'édifice qui s'est effondrée sur eux
ma fille est morte sur le cou Dieu est
son âme dit-elle mon fils et moi on est
resté piégé sous les décombres il
faisait noir on a beaucoup crié à l'aide
on aurait voulu de l'eau mais personne
ne venait
cet homme dit habitique de 62 ans est
resté coincé dans les débris avec une
bouteille d'eau et un tapis qui l'a
gardé au chaud il a crié à l'aide
pendant près de huit jours avant
d'entendre du bruit au-dessus de lui
j'ai finalement vu un trou dans les
débris dit-il quand j'ai entendu les
voix des secouristes j'ai recommencé à
crier même si j'avais la gorge enflée
d'avoir beaucoup crié quand il a tendu
un bras vers moi j'ai mis ma main dans
la sienne
la nuit dernière un premier convoi
d'aide humanitaire est arrivé dans le
nord-ouest de la Syrie une région
contrôlée par des rebelles le président
syrien Bachar al-Assad aurait accepté
mardi d'ouvrir plus de poste frontières
pour permettre à l'aide de se rendre
dans ses régions des millions de
sinistrés syriens n'ont pas encore
trouvé d'abris et non reçu aucune aide
de l'extérieur jusqu'ici
qu'après un séisme la communauté
internationale il l'ONU n'est pas les
victimes les Nations Unies ont échoué
lamentablement
le patron des casques blancs c'est
secouriste spécialisé dans la recherche
de victimes dans les décombres après un
bombardement ou un séisme déplore aussi
que la Syrie n'a reçu aucune machinerie
lourde pour aider ces hommes à sauver
plus de survivre
ici Sophie Langlois Radio-Canada
Montréal